bientôt deux mois qu'ils sont mobilisés
chaque jour présent sur ce rond-point
dans le nord du département oms et gilet
jaune
le débat national est synonyme d'espoir
mais tous ne sont pas convaincus
on va pas rester à manifester encore six
mois de l'année il va falloir quand même
commencé à discuter et et qu'ils
prennent conscience des choses et qu'on
avance il n'y a pas cinquante chose il
faut vraiment rien se mettre autour
d'une table et discuter l'attenté les
grandes oui mais d'un autre côté on
n'est pas convaincu on n'y croit pas
quand on voit comment a réagi le
gouvernement comment réagit le président
depuis le début on est vraiment
on est sceptique sur le résultat pour
l'heure c'est gilet jaune déplore
surtout le manque de communication et
d'information de la part des autorités
quant au débat national dominique
bourreau pourtant maire de la commune
dit ne pas en savoir plus l'élu a reçu
et centraliser les doléances de ses
administrés et constate lui aussi une
grande attente chez les habitants il
espère que le débat national sont à y
répondre par des mesures concrètes pour
qu'ils prennent un sens il faut
absolument que l' annonce soit faite que
ce débat pourra influer les politiques
sinon je pense que les gens s'en
détourneront tout simplement le débat
national doit débuter la semaine
prochaine à villeneuve la guyard les
habitants attendent désormais de savoir
comment y participer